hey leute viele leute haben mich danach
gefragt und jetzt habe ich auch gemacht
weil das letzte video da auch 2006 hatte
der erstes kind contest und zwar habe
ich dann gefragt wollt ihr dass ich mir
ein skin pack mache was jetzt so einige
youtuber schon gemacht haben deswegen
habe ich jetzt 1 anfertigen lassen und
zwar von lavive der kanal
stellenbeschreibung ich wollte
eigentlich selber machen jetzt gefragt
soll ich jetzt machen ich hab sogar
schon lange von habe ich gesagt ja okay
dann kannst du es auch übernehmen
danke auch an dich auf jeden fall es
sind nämlich 767 skins in diesem pack
drin er findet den downloadlink in der
beschreibung einfach draufklicken
download des media feier des alle said
und zwar immer conny man das ist batmans
gehen mit meiner contractor maske mit
der wille die maske dann einmal krieg
akon kräfte also ich mit der ein skin
mit seiner crew baske dann einmal
schwein kraft also mainz gewinner
schweinsmasken dann einmal nackt akon
kraft also eine person die nackt ist nur
mit der maske dann ein vor lincoln ii
also mainz kind mit dem kopf von dieser
dings von dem wie heißt er von diesem
könig da dann ein unkonkreter also das
ist ungeheuer maske von ungespielt mit
meinem skin und dann noch ein zombie con
kraft also eine zombie maske und dann
mein skin und ich hoffe einfach euch
gefällt der skin pack dann gebt einfach
den daumen hoch wenn ich das eventuell
noch erweitern soll dann will ich dann
den downloadlink nochmal updaten dann
geht einfach darum hoch wenn ihr das
wollt können wir auch in die kommentare
schreiben was ich eventuell noch dazu
fügen könnte und dann denke ich das mal
so ein bisschen ab den downloadlink in
der beschreibung und dann würde ich erst
mal sagen noch mal danke einander tief
und download link in der beschreibung
könnt ihr euch runterladen und ja-cheol